the rhine river is a major transport
artery
for over a century it's been integral to
the rhineland's chemical industry
evonique is one of the biggest chemical
companies in germany
with its headquarters on the outskirts
of bonn
around 1300 people work here the
acceptance
the region's acceptance of the industry
is a major factor
that means we have a good standing in
the area
we have high training standards for our
workers because the industry is a
tradition in the region
the company makes specialty chemicals
such as silicic acid crystals
it produces about 1.6 million tons of it
per year
new production facilities are tried out
here in the test laboratory
in chemistry silica is an important
catalyst support
it's found in car tires toothpaste in
matting agents to make them more
efficient or on furniture surfaces as a
scratch protection
silica results from a chemical reaction
between sodium silicate
also known as water glass and sulfuric
acid
the market has become more competitive
of late with china and the us fast
catching up with evanic
the company will be investing 4 billion
euros in r d in the next 10 years
there is rising demand for
environmentally sustainable products
as consumers will only have better and
more sustainable solutions if existing
processes are improved
together with our customers
we need to work on solutions that
address the issue of sustainability
in terms of resource efficiency and
environmental protection
and
areas of research is the green tire
tires contain not only rubber and carbon
black but also silica
the components determine the tire type
with the right mix the tire can reduce a
car's gas consumption by 10 for example
around 2500 different tire mixtures are
manufactured a year
and they all need to be tested
how long do they last how well do they
break on wet ground
a green tire certification was
introduced in 2012.
standards have risen so steeply that we
need to launch what's called a double a
tire
a for optimized rolling resistance or
gas consumption and another a for grip
on wet roads
from its base in the rhineland evonique
supplies the world's leading tire
manufacturers
one-third of car tires now sold
internationally are green tires
worldwide it's a billion euro market